Allah says in surah chapter number 17
verse number 110man
say call upon him by Allah or by him by
whichever name you call upon him to him
belongs the most beautiful name you can
call Allah by any name but it should be
a beautiful name and it should be a name
given by him
not by yourself [clears throat] and
there are no less than 99 attributes and
names given to Allah subhanana wa tala
in the glorious Quran
And the crowning one is Allah.
Why do we Muslims prefer calling Allah
by the Arabic word Allah instead of the
English word God?
Because the English word God can be
played around with. For example, if you
add S to God, it becomes God's plural of
God. There's no plural.
If you add d e ss to god, it becomes
goddess, meaning a female god. There is
no male Allah or female Allah in Islam.
If you add father to God, it becomes
godfather. He's my godfather. There's
nothing like Allah father or Allah aba
in Islam. If you add mother to god, it
becomes godmother. There's nothing like
Allah mother, Allah am in Islam. If you
prefix attend before god, it becomes tin
god, meaning a fake god. There's nothing
like tin Allah. So Allah is an unique
word. It's an Arabic word which is
unique. That's the reason we Muslims we
prefer calling Allah by the Arabic word
Allah instead of the English word God.
And the beauty is that most of the
scriptures that came before Quran even
though they have been changed yet Allah
is there. We were talking about the
Hindu scriptures.
There is an upanishad called as Allah
punisher.
If you read sik religion, one of the
attributes of God is Allah.
If you read the Bible, it's mentioned in
the Bible in the Gospel of Matthew
chapter number 27
verse number 39 and Gospel of Mark
chapter number 15:34 when Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was put on the cross,
he cried out,
If you translate into Arabic, Allah
English, oh God, oh God, why hast thou
forsaken me? So when he said, oh God, he
said Allah. If you read the Scoffield
reference Bible,
Allah is spelled as A L A H.
Minor difference. Allah. Allah. So even
Jesus Christ when he called almighty god
in his own language they use the word
Allah
this unique word Allah
for almighty god is there in the
scripture of most of the major religion
that's the reason we Muslims we prefer
calling Allah by the Arabic word Allah
instead of the English word God
most of the other religions besides
[snorts] Islam
they believe in a philosophy called as
anthropomorphism.
Anthropomorphism means almighty god
taking form.
For example, if almighty god wants to
come for the human being, he comes in a
human form.
And they have a beautiful logic. Their
logic is
that almighty god is so holy, so pure,
so sublime. He does not know the
shortcomings of the human being. How
does it feel when you in trouble? How
does it feel when you are in problem?
So almighty God became a human being to
know what is good or what is bad for the
human being. Very good logic.
But I tell them if you manufacture a DVD
player or you manufacture an electronic
equipment, do you have to become a DVD
player to know what is good or what is
bad for the DVD player? No. If you are
the creator, you know what is good and
bad? Don't have to become that thing.
What do you do? You write an instruction
manual.
The dos and the don'ts for that machine
is written in the instruction manual by
the creator, by the inventor, by the
manufacturer.
If you buy a DVD player, it says that if
you want to play, insert the DVD, press
the play button. If you want fast
forward, press the FF button. Stop. If
you want stop it, stop stop button.
Don't drop it from height. It will get
spoiled. Don't immerse it in water. It
will get spoiled.
The instruction manual tells you the dos
and don'ts. So if you allow me to call
the human being the machine,
you'll have to agree that human being is
the most complicated machine on the face
of the earth. Don't you think it
requires the instruction manual? The
instruction manual for the human beings.
It is a glorious Quran. The glorious
Quran which is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
revealed to the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him is
the instruction manual. The instruction
manual is for the human being. The dos
and don'ts for a human being is
mentioned in the glorious Quran.
Allah doesn't have to become a human
being to know what is good or bad for
them. What does he do? He chooses a man
amongst men and he communicates with
them on a higher level which we call as
messengers of God.
He sends down messengers of God
to deliver his message amongst the human
beings.
And this concept is there in most of the
major religions also.
So if you read the Quran, you'll
understand Islam in the right
perspective.